[Musique]
cette petite maison de banlieue à 30
minutes du centre de baltimore et la
propriété est aussi la fierté de la
famille santos
sandra santos et ses trois filles sont
déjà rentrés du travail et de l'école et
elles attendent mario comme tous les
soirs
mais depuis janvier dernier cette
routine est perturbée par une crainte
profonde celle de tout perdre de tout
devoir quitter emploi maison amis
d'école et d'être forcé de retourner
dans le pays d'origine des parents
santos le salvador
nous travaillons légalement et dieu
merci nous avons pu acquérir une maison
pour vivre dignement
on n'a qu'à sa gloire des noms la
famille grandit et nous ne pouvons pas
aller n'importe où
il est bien loin le salvador sandra et
mario l'ont quittée en 1998 vingt ans
qu'il profite de la protection spéciale
temporaire tps en anglais accordées par
le gouvernement américain à des victimes
des guerres civiles en amérique centrale
des ouragans ou des séismes qui ont
ravagé la région
mario est tailleur de granit pour
comptoirs de cuisine
sandra est en pack 2 de poulet dans une
usine leur fille fatima sandraz
esmeralda et stéphanie sont américaines
né aux états unis elles sont bilingues
leur anglais est impeccable l'aîné n'a
que 12 ans il faudrait qu'elle et 21 ans
pour parrainer ses parents pour
l'immigration
mario perdra son statut protégé dans 18
mois
[Musique]
comme lui à cette date deux cent mille
salvadorien perdront leur statut et
devront normalement être expulsé vers le
salvador 57 mille citoyens du honduras
dans la même situation
suivront en 2020 ceux qui vivent à
baltimore compte un peu de chance ils
peuvent obtenir de l'aide
baltimore est une ville d'immigration
depuis toujours depuis l'europe
autrefois puis cuba dans les années 60
et maintenant d'amérique centrale sans
les immigrants récents baltimore était
voué un déclin désastreux ce sont eux
qui stimule l'économie de la région
la ville leur offre des services l'état
du maryland aussi et il y a les ong
depuis 55 ans catholic charities possède
le centre esperanza qui offre une foule
de services à tous les immigrants
services médicaux dentaires cours de
langue etc et surtout un service
juridique qui tourne un plein depuis
quelques mois est en situation d'urgence
le service juridique se compose de dix
experts permanent et d'une centaine de
bénévoles
le principal obstacle de tous ceux qui
ont un statut protégé temporaire menacés
d'expulsion et le manque d'accès à un
avocat
il y en a des dizaines de milliers qui
n'ont pas d'argent pour voir un avocat
ou ne savent pas comment faire
à baltimore les églises bâti autrefois
par les immigrants irlandais italiens ou
polonais font aujourd'hui le plein de
fidèles venus d'amérique centrale du
salvador en particulier comme la
paroisse du sacré coeur où officie le
père bruce c'est à lui qu'il vienne
confier leur désarroi
je ne crois pas qu'on comprenne
l'ampleur du sentiment anti migrants
croissant dans ce pays ces dernières
années et nous sous-estimons ses effets
sur les gens l'insécurité la crainte
l'angoissé le stress que ça provoque le
président entre hommes venaient tout
juste de qualifier des immigrants
d'animaux il parlait des bandes
criminelles ms-13 les mara salvatrucha
semé tous se sont sentis visés de nos
paroissiens vous un sans abri qui
mendient dans la rue il lui donne de
l'argent par la fenêtre de son auto sans
abri prend l'argent et lui dit tu es un
immigrant tu n'a rien à faire ici va
attraper ces derniers mois la police
d'immigration américaine redoublent de
zèle sa chasse aux clandestins bat son
plein officiellement on cherche les
délinquants mais dans les faits tous
ceux qui ont un air latino sont visés
[Musique]
qu'il n'est pas facile de rencontrer ces
immigrants menacé par les mesures
trempent leur cas sont délicats leur
crainte est naturelle ce sont le père
bruce et le père edmundo qui nous ont
permis de les approcher du jour au
lendemain dans la communauté on
s'aperçoit que son voisin son ami sont
parents risquent de perdre tout ce
qu'ils ont tous se connaissent
ainsi ces jeunes gens viennent du
salvador du honduras du guatemala
ils vivent tous aux états unis il
également pourquoi grillen ça fait 14
ans il avait 19 ans à son arrivée
malgré les dieux merci j'ai appris
l'anglais je suis mécanicien
j'aide ma famille mon père a pu finir
ses études à présent il est hanté par la
perspective de tomber dans un piège de
la police d'immigration ice
il y a déjà échappé de justesse il y à
quelques temps
marcelino ersilia herrera reviennent du
honduras aux états unis depuis 1996 ils
travaillent sont propriétaires paient
des impôts y envoient de l'argent alors
trois enfants restés au pays
ils sont abasourdis par la fin de leur
statut de protection
ils ne savent pas quoi faire allez au
canada est une option pour eux oui c'est
possible nous irons canada ou en espagne
le honduras n'est pas une option pour le
moment trop dangereux le honduras tout
comme le salvador pour la famille santos
pour eux aussi le canada serait un plan
b les familles avaient un mental
ma famille et moi nous avons parlé de
trouver refuge au canada
ce serait la seule option parce que nous
ne voulons pas revenir en arrière
une situation pas facile à vivre pour
une jeune fille de 12 ans 120 tonnes
déficit c'est dur de voir un père de
famille ou un parent qui se fait enlever
par la police migratoire devant ses
propres enfants
les religieux les santos espère un
miracle
le père el mundo ne peut pas leur en
promettre mais il leur assure que
l'église ne restera pas inactive et que
quand toutes les voix s'unissent il se
passe quelque chose comme de la route
allopass a ce quelque chose serait la
mise en échec des politiques anti
immigrants du président trompe